comprendre non on ne peut que la la
respecter ou la subir
moi j'ai été épargnée parce que j'avais
déjà fait la démarche de partir deux ans
avant mais donc je l'ai pris beaucoup de
recul mais j'étais très heureuse qu'on
me propose de revenir pour la fin ça m'a
permis de d'accompagner un petit peu mes
camarades de leur montrer qu'il y avait
une vie aussi après en parallèle et puis
pour le public ça a fait un joli clin
d'oeil et ça a permis aussi de
comprendre la fin de du personnage parce
qu'on savait être un petit peu précipité
donc comprendre non mais par contre on
ne sait jamais dans la vie peut tout y
avoir des surprises des primes on ne
sait pas ça peut peut-être revenir alors
pourquoi pas à l'instant T non mais
attention je suis pas en train de donner
un scoop mais dans la vie rien n'est
figé la vie comment tu as réagi quand tu
as appris la règle moi je suis croyais
pas je pensais que c'était une vanne en
fait moi aussi mais en même temps alors
au contraire de de Fabienne moi ça ne
m'étonne pas il faut que un moment
effectivement il y ait un renouveau donc
là ça semblait être une une
la fin de cycle en fait alors moi aussi
j'étais parti il y a plus d'un an mais
lorsque j'ai appris le truc j'étais
évidemment surpris un peu un peu déçu
mais on y réfléchissant c'est pas très
étonnant il faut il faut une fin d'une
aventure pour que à nouveau il y ait
quelque chose de un souffle nouveau et
ben question c'est est-ce que Marseille
est-ce que les productions parisiennes
vont
reproduire quelque chose à Marseille et
redonner et redonner vie
aux techniciens aux acteurs qui sont
là-bas qui sont formidables bien sûr on
va on va revenir sur ta première
apparition à Fabienne regarde tu te
rappelles la première apparition
on peut savoir qui vous êtes parce que
vous rentrez chez les gens sans prévenir
je suis la sœur du mec qui habitait ici
il est où maintenant il vit chez Céline
Frémont sa meuf
il vivait ensemble depuis quelques temps
j'ai eu donné son adresse
merci
[Applaudissements]
Lola toi tu es triste que ça s'arrête
quand même on est tous tristes forcément
de quoi
moi je l'ai appris parce que vous m'avez
invité pour venir me parler comment tu
l'as acheté un coup de fil en fait voilà
pour venir en parlant plus belle la vie
s'arrête est-ce que tu veux venir en
parler j'ai dit pardon
je te jure c'est vrai c'est quelqu'un de
chez toi qui m'a dit est-ce que tu viens
ce soir pourquoi faire parfois des mecs
tu savais que ta meuf était plus avec
toi
j'attends que vous m'appeliez je me dis
merde qu'est-ce que j'ai fait qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait quoi donc
j'étais halluciné j'ai dit m'attendais
il y a un bruit qui court comme quoi ça
s'arrête et tout et après voilà je suis
un peu comme avis c'est vrai que tout a
une fin c'est une série qui a 18 ans qui
s'était énormément amélioré la
dernièrement en plus c'est-à-dire qu'il
y avait énormément de tournage en
extérieur qui avait pas ça a commencé là
quand on voit les extraits avec la
mienne tout était en studio etc donc
évidemment là on accédait à de la
politique
des comédiens qui étaient là depuis 15
ans 15 ans 10 ans pardon
mais non pour le coup j'ai halluciné et
après je me suis dit c'est la vie moi
honnêtement tout personnellement je suis
quelqu'un qui aime bien me renouveler
qui aime bien me mettre en danger donc
j'étais quelque part contente aussi que
le destin me force un petit peu à me
relever les mains j'ai tu vois et à
retourner travailler mais après c'est
vrai que ce qui fait de la peine surtout
c'est que on est une bande d'amis on est
une vraie famille et que ben c'est à
dire c'est comme tu vois quand tu vas au
collège au lycée ou au travail et que tu
es content de comme vous quoi de vous
retrouver nous on avait ce plaisir là
qui voilà peut-être pas mais peut-être
moi c'est vrai que on est plus content
de retrouver
dans la série tu avais quelque chose en
commun avec Fabienne c'était un homme
exactement
j'aime tout
j'espère qu'elle te rend bien
tous les jours
jamais dans mes rêves les plus fous
j'aurais imaginé à tel bonheur
c'est pas moi
je te taquine c'est bon
non j'aime bien en fait quand tu me fais
rêver en me racontant ton bonheur
conjugal dans 60 mètres carrés c'est sûr
on avait prévu de déménager mais là il
va falloir le faire
alors pourquoi la vie on a essayé de
revenir sur un moment culte de ton
histoire en plus Belle La Vie regarde et
puis il y a une question qui vient de
tomber avec quelqu'un qui voulait te
poser une question à un téléspectateur
regarde
je comprends pas bien pourquoi vous
voulez me revoir
puisque après deux orgasmes moi je
m'endors
vous êtes capable de mieux non
non moi c'est un orgasme et
je m'en fous des partenaires qui
manquaient enthousiasme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde tu vois ton Jean-Marie ta femme
est là donc c'est plus rapide
il y a quelqu'un qui a vraiment manqué
dans le dernier prime
je regrette aussi de pas y avoir été en
même temps je enfin voilà ça faisait à
peine un an que j'étais parti ça me
semblait assez normal que
ouais que j'apparaisse pas dans
l'histoire
sans savoir que la série allait
s'arrêter je j'avais résonné de la même
façon que ce que je viens de te dire
c'est-à-dire je pense qu'il y a une fin
à tout et qu'il fallait partir sur
d'autres d'autres projets et voilà je
les gens qui m'aiment bien parfois
disent mais oui mais parti tu es parti
donc la série peut plus marcher non non
mais
un peu non non mais bon voilà je sentais
que c'était la fin on voulait revoir des
images de la vie parce que c'est vrai
que vous cogniez vraiment à l'actu moi
c'est ça qui m'ont demandé il faut que
je trouvais ça génial donc plus belle la
vie c'est vraiment il y avait un un fait
d'actualité qui se passait dans la
journée je sais pas comment faisait ou
non et le lendemain tu avais dans
l'épisode tu avais un regard regardez
ils ont par exemple rendu hommage à
beaucoup de personnes qui ont disparu
pendant le taux pendant la diffusion de
Plus Belle La Vie regardez
vous voulez qu'on appelle un
professionnel place des As oh non plutôt
un prêtre Léon Morin
Babel est partie
de Jacques Chirac hier
je te promets
si c'est pas des [ __ ] de souvenirs ça
alors vous étiez au vélo de Rome oui
évidemment c'est fou le monde qui avait
d'ailleurs pour rendre hommage à Bernard
Tapie j'imagine demain parce que ça va
être
j'avais peur qu'il parle de moi
[Rires]
Raymond je sais que tu es vénère toi de
la République moi oui parce que c'est
les gens aiment bien plus belle la vie
moi j'ai pas regardé souvent pour être
honnête et les gens adoraient ce
feuilleton et je dis que quand je dis
que la télé est quand même un monde
méchant ils l'ont même pas invité il a
fait ça pendant 10 ans ils n'ont même
pas invité pour la pour la dernière
émission pour la dernière la dernière
série merci Raymond pour le moment
il est pas là dedans
il y a beaucoup d'acteurs qui ont tu te
rends compte il y a eu plus de plus de
3000 comédiens ils ont tous fait 10 ans
et pardon il s'est barré aussi un an
avant
pour le problème n'est-ce pas non plus
en fantôme en fait donc j'étais morte
mon personnage était mort donc Daniel
[Rires]
et moi c'est juste une décision que moi
j'ai prise un an avant et il y a eu
tellement de personnages dans cette
série qui pouvaient évidemment pas
rappeler tout le monde pour le dernier
épisode et et d'ailleurs je trouve que
les anciens qui sont revenus ont créé
une espèce de surprise et de plaisir
supplémentaire aux gens qui regardaient
moi il venaient de me voir partir donc
il y avait pas réellement de de surprise
à leur à leur procurer voilà alors c'est
vrai que moi je vais vous dire moi je
suis triste de la République
les audiences je faisais pas encore télé
tout le monde se moquer de Plus belle la
vie ça avait démarré très très bas c'est
monté monter monter et à un moment tout
le monde a voulu copier Plus belle la
vie il y a des modes en télé et là voilà
Plus belle la vie on monte tout le monde
a voulu copier donc il y a eu plein de
feuilletons d'ailleurs qui sont créés et
d'ailleurs celui qui marchait le mieux
c'est celui qui pour le culte ça restera
plus belle la vie je suis contrôler
demain nous appartient ou aujourd'hui
les gens les forces vivent de Plus belle
la vie ont été créés
demain tout commence
ici
tout commence
la décision a été quand même prise un
peu en douce et puis il y a tous cette
techniciens tout le pôle de lui il va
vouloir
il va vouloir vous faire balancer lui le
pôle honnêtement je vous trouve gentil
avec la police c'est vrai qu'il y a tous
les techniciens qui sont malades et là
on nous promet une sorte de reprise à
Marseille etc mais ça très franchement
c'est pour faire avaler la pilule c'est
du vent vous pensez franchement je pense
pas il y a un programme de projet une
SCOP c'est-à-dire voilà où on serait
tous actionnaires
une coopérative
qu'on y croit ou pas c'est en tout cas
quelque chose qui qui est en pour parler
avec new Wayne et qui pourrait
éventuellement peut-être voir le jour
sur une plateforme voilà
effectivement c'est que les productions
que ce soit telle France ou autre
se réintéresse à cette ville qui est
extraordinaire pour tourner c'est
effectivement la raison pour laquelle
une des raisons pour lesquelles cette
série a marché c'est que les décors sont
fabuleux la lumière et extraordinaire et
que pour y tourner c'est un lieu de
prédilection donc il faut simplement
qu'une idée resurgisse de la tête d'un
d'un auteur et que et que des
productions s'intéressent parce que il y
a effectivement des lieux il y a des
techniciens il y a des acteurs il y a
tout ce qu'il faut pour faire pour
refaire naître quelque chose d'aussi
fort que Plus belle la vie dans Plus
belle la vie ils avaient tourné aussi
deux fins pour l'élection présidentielle
2007 une avec la victoire de Nicolas
Sarkozy l'autre avec la victoire de
Ségolène Royal regardez
la moitié de la population sur le
carreau comme aux États-Unis enfin c'est
pas mieux de laisser une France à genoux
avec une politique sociale aberrante
messieurs les cafés c'est pour moi pour
fêter la soirée d'hier on avait pas
regardé la télé monsieur Frémont si
Monsieur Thomas mais je ne vois vraiment
pas ce qu'il y a fêter au long de
président mais c'est la débâcle moi je
suis plutôt content on va pouvoir
respirer changer les choses avec ce
guignol vous plaisantez vous exagérez un
peu non mais c'est un mollusque votre
Hollande
dans les grands événements de l'actu il
y avait également le mariage homosexuel
en 2013 là encore la série live ok
regardez
monsieur Gabriel Riva acceptez-vous de
prendre pour époux Monsieur Thomas Marci
oui monsieur Thomas Marcy acceptez-vous
de prendre pour époux monsieur Gabriel
Riva
au nom de la loi nous vous déclarons
époux et Marie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je peux dire quelque chose c'est pour
moi c'est ça le la tristesse que cette
série s'arrête c'est que aucune autre
c'est pourtant qui sait pourtant calqué
sur Plus Belle La Vie en termes de de
mode de fabrication aucune autre
n'offrait cette possibilité là de parler
de tous ces sujets de société et et
c'est l'ADN de Plus belle la vie qu'on a
perdu et en ça effectivement on peut
être tous très triste parce que rien ne
peut remplacer cette série pour ces
raisons par exemple depuis que ça a été
annoncé que c'est fini et tout tous les
jours je reçois mes gens je sais pas à
une vingtaine de messages par jour de
gens qui me disent tu vas tellement nous
manquer et vraiment j'ai l'impression
d'être malade que je vais mourir c'est à
dire que j'arrête pas de leur dire mais
je suis pas morte enfin tu vois il y a
quelque chose de on était tellement chez
les gens tous les soirs et les gens ont
vraiment que mais moi j'ai l'impression
que je vais décéder quoi non non je
crois je crois pas alors il y a un truc
à cette émission en même temps il y a un
truc que les scénaristes n'ont jamais
voulu évoquer et la pandémie du covid-19
considéré que c'était trop anxiogène
cette histoire de de de virus un autre
truc aussi c'est la prochaine soirée de
Daniel Moreau puisqu'ils ont anticipé
à une heure de grande écoute la série
avait aussi montré les débuts d'un plan
à trois
entre Marine la surveillance du lycée
Stéphane prieur et l'infirmier voilà et
c'est vrai que
les voix inali à tour de rôle du Popper
ce sera rappelle on l'avait passé ici ça
voilà et c'est vrai que tout le monde au
moins Plus belle la vie ça faisait
parler moi
c'est sûr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en famille au vu de la longévité de la
série vous avez commencé il y avait pas
les réseaux sociaux et finalement la
série est continue avec les réseaux
sociaux est-ce que ça a modifié à votre
avis votre manière d'incarner les
personnages l'écriture les thèmes les
polémiques et tout ça avec les réseaux
sociaux on a un retour direct quand il y
a une intrigue qui bouscule ou le
personnage qui fait quelque chose qui ne
plaît pas au public on a des
commentaires dans un sens ou dans
l'autre et forcément là oui il y a un
retour direct qu'on n'avait pas au tout
au début au début on attend on a vu
juste un rapport dans la rue les gens se
retrouvent dans la rue mais là sur les
réseaux sociaux ça peut être plus
violent parce que bien sûr les gens sont
couverts on le sait donc oui ça change
un petit peu à ce niveau là mais il y a
aussi beaucoup comme disait Lola
beaucoup beaucoup de messages très
gentils alors il y a une des scènes qui
a particulièrement choquée aussi été
spectateur c'est cette confrontation
entre un policier Patrick et un criminel
ça avait choqué voilà les gens dans leur
téléphone
j'en ai marre de choquer polémique tout
ça quand tu fais parler c'est que tu
existes regarde
je te crève
c'est mignon comme ça là
je te dis
ça tombe bien j'ai toujours rêvé de me
taper un flic
[Musique]
reste à faire
pour le coup je crois je crois
moi ça me dérange
beaucoup de monde
par exemple que pour Jérôme Bertin qui
joue
le commandant debout ça a été une de ses
plus de ces arches les plus
intéressantes à jouer il a été très très
impliqué dans cette dans ce travail là
il était très très heureux de enfin très
heureux
de devoir aborder le sujet du viol
masculin
et voilà et c'est ça aussi qui qu'a
porté cette série c'est que on avait la
possibilité moi j'ai joué donc un
journaliste un peu voilà qui qui disait
ouais force que les gens ne voulaient
pas entendre et qui se fait jeter à la
figure de la soude j'ai joué donc la
cécité pendant presque presque un an et
c'était très fort et je sais que que
c'est un truc qui reviendra peut-être
pas de sitôt quoi ça vient toi c'est
trop là moi je oui moi ça me dérange
mais moi je suis pas je suis un peu
baignée oui moi je
mais c'est que ça fonctionne c'est que
ça marche et c'est que on y croit ça
existe mais je veux dire on tourne vite
on tourne donc c'est bien que quand on
croit des scènes comme ça avec voilà je
trouve que c'est gratifiant pour la
série mais ça j'aime moi je suis
d'accord avec Fabienne là la série elle
est trop loin
la série elle est là c'est limite moins
12 quoi et ma question c'est est-ce qu'à
force d'aller trop loin
ce n'est pas en partie responsable
arrête arrête
mais va sur France Inter
j'ai raison non mais parce qu'il veut
pécho non mais là où il a raison c'est
que il y a des gens qui ont du décrocher
parce que ça les a dérangés et ils
aiment bien si il y a plein de gens qui
ont bien aimé le côté qui met bien le
côté familial du début avec les
personnages du début et à la fois il
faut aussi bousculer il faut couper le
côté
on évolue et là c'est obligé d'évolué
c'est à dire que voilà il y a des vrais
gens qui préférait certaines arches et
et et d'autres moins en fait cette série
elle était unique pour ça c'est qu'elle
abordé des sujets de société ce sujet
existe et c'est très bien qu'on en parle
de regarder
là là on vous a choisi des excuses
on en a trouvé trois en 18 ans et
peut-être les enfants comment tu sais
c'est sur la santé
on a cherché on a trouvé 3 ou 18 ans le
maximum du sujet c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
pas plus c'est quand même très suggéré
quand même cette fille plus il y a le
pétard dans le cul mais là là je
préférais quand tu dormais merci
ce qui est fou ils ont même parlé de moi
et de l'émission dans Plus Belle La Vie
regardez ils ont même parlé de Mokhtar
ça va
ça lui plaît pas de t'avoir dérangé
tu te souviens de Mokhtar
le sosie de Cyril Hanouna
j'ai vu sa femme ce matin elle m'a dit
il s'est fait serrer par les flics
ah merde
[Applaudissements]